foreign  this man is my prisoner  you're Robbie Cole right  you're in Swanson  another Bounty Hunter  yeah your dad and I used to work  together he made a lot of enemies  cracking a real whale of the bounty are  you dangerous not to my friends well  that's too bad because I have enough  friends  El Gringo Narco biggest meth operation  in the midwest I'll make Maui the  international drug port  a toast in the new Maui from now on  everybody's wishes come true he's a  stone cold killer tied to the cartels  word of advice I would leave this island  and not come back you want to get to  work or not  I'm still  but there's a lot of influence on this  island don't you ever doubt me  I think I'll drown if we're lucky make  sure he's dead before he leaves his  property  chance  foreign  are you too stupid to die you've been  chasing me for 10 years I'm a little OCD